VP’S LIST FOR JOE BIDEN.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT AS WELL.
OUR TOP STORY BEGINS TONIGHT
WITH A FORMER HOUSE INSIDE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TREY GOWDY AND WHAT
THE VICE PRESIDENT KNEW IF
ANYTHING ABOUT THE INSURANCE
POLICY THAT WE TALK SO MUCH
ABOUT.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
SO I THOUGHT WE WOULD START BY
TAKING A LOOK AT THIS TWEET BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE SAID, "IF I WERE A SENATOR OR
CONGRESSMAN, THE FIRST PERSON
THAT I WOULD CALL TO TESTIFY
ABOUT THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
CRIME AND SCANDAL IN THE HISTORY
OF THE USA BY FAR IS FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HE KNEW EVERYTHING."
THE PRESIDENT WRITES IN CAPS,
"DO IT, SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM,
JUST DO IT.
NO MORE MR. NICE GUY, NO MORE
TALK."
AND HERE IS THE RESPONSE BY
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM TO THAT
TWEET.
LET’S WATCH THAT.
>> NO PRESIDENT IS ABOVE THE LAW
BUT WE DO HAVE SEPARATIONS OF
POWERS AND I THINK IT WOULD BE A
BAD PRECEDENT TO COMPEL A FORMER
PRESIDENT TO COME BEFORE
CONGRESS.
WOULD OPEN UP A CAN OF WORMS FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS, I DON’T
THINK THAT’S A GOOD IDEA.
>> Martha: SO WHO DO YOU AGREE
WITH HERE?
>> LET ME SAY THIS, I UNDERSTAND
FULLY WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
FRUSTRATED.
HIS FIRST TERM IN OFFICE HAS
BEEN UNDER A MANUFACTURED CLOUD
BY HIS OPPONENTS.
SO I UNDERSTAND HIS FRUSTRATION.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT MY ADVICE
TO REPUBLICANS WOULD BE WE ARE
FIVE MONTHS AWAY FROM THE
GENERAL ELECTION, THE HOUSES UP
AND A THIRD OF THE SUN IS UP,
LET’S NOT FIGHT PUBLICLY AND
HAVE THESE INTER-NESTING BATTLES
FIVE MONTHS BEFORE THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK YOU SHOULD
DO.
FIRST OF ALL, GET ALL THE
DOCUMENTS ON THE EVIDENCE.
THERE IS A PART OF THAT EMAIL
THAT NO ONE’S EVER READ BECAUSE
IT STILL CLASSIFIED.
HOW ABOUT ANY TEXT WITH ANDY
McCABE AND JIM COMEY?
THERE WERE A LOT OF DOCUMENTS
THAT NEED TO BE DECLASSIFIED,
AND IF I CALL PRESIDENT OBAMA,
HE WOULD BE THE LAST WITNESS
BECAUSE I DON’T LIKE SURPRISES.
THIS IS NOT A MYSTERY.
THIS IS NOT ENTERTAINMENT.
WE ARE TRYING TO PERSUADE AND
COMMUNICATE.
YOU ALREADY KNOW WHAT SAMANTHA
POWER AND SUSAN RICE AND
McCABE AND JAMES COMEY AND
CLAPPER WHAT ROLE THEY PLAY.
SO LAY THAT OUT FOR THE JURY,
AND THEN I WOULD CALL BIDEN
BEFORE I CALLED PRESIDENT OBAMA
BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
IMPEACHED FOR TRYING TO
INVESTIGATE HIS POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
MAYBE THAT’S WHAT BIDEN DID.
I DON’T KNOW IT BUT IF IT’S GOOD
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, WOULDN’T IT
BE GOOD FOR BIDEN AND WOULDN’T
YOU WANT TO KNOW THAT?
>> Martha: HERE’S THE
QUESTION.
WITH REGARD TO THE NAMES ON THIS
UNMASKING LIST, IT’S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT MAY OR MAY
NOT MEAN MUCH, THAT SOME OF
THOSE NAMES ARE THERE BECAUSE
SOMEONE ELSE ASKED THEM TO PUT
THEIR NAME ON THE UNMASKING
REQUEST AND THEN PERHAPS THE
PERSON WHO WAS BEHIND MOST OF
THE DESIRE TO UNMASK THOSE
DOESN’T HAVE THEIR NAME ON THAT
LIST AT ALL.
DOES THAT ADD UP TO YOU?
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> IT DOES NOT.
I HEARD THAT FROM SAMANTHA
POWER.
IN THE NUMBER OF UNMASKING SUCH
SHE REQUESTED WAS SO FAR OUTSIDE
THE REALM, AND THEN SHE SAID SHE
DIDN’T KNOW ABOUT MOST OF THEM,
BUT THAT’S THE PROBLEM IS AND
IT?
YOU GIVE THE POWER TO SOMEONE TO
UNMASK AND THEY ARE DELEGATING
THAT POWER TO A CLERK OR A
SUBORDINATE, THIS IS THE
QUESTION FOR JOE BIDEN.
WE KNOW YOU ASKED TO UNMASK
MICHAEL FLYNN’S NAME.
WE KNOW THAT.
HOW MANY OTHER UNMASKING REQUEST
DID YOU MAKE?
WERE YOU A SERIAL UNMASK HER
WHILE YOU ARE THE VICE PRESIDENT
OR WAS THIS THE ONLY ONE?
I CAN’T ANSWER THAT QUESTION,
BUT I THINK IT’S REALLY RELEVANT
RELEVANT.
>> Martha: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
BECAUSE IN TERMS OF THIS BATTLE
OVER WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD
GO SO FAR UP IN TERMS OF
INVESTIGATION INTO JOE BIDEN FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA, THERE IS NO
INDICATION THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE OR THAT JOHN DURHAM
ARE CONSIDERING EITHER ONE OF
THOSE TWO PEOPLE THAT I JUST
NAMED IN THEIR INVESTIGATION,
AND WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH HUGH HEWITT JUST
A SHORT WHILE BACK, THE END
OF APRIL.
WATCH THIS.
>> AS FAR AS I’M AWARE, NONE OF
THE PEOPLE WHOSE ACTIONS ARE
BEING REVIEWED AT THIS POINT ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Martha: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT?
>> FOLLOW THE EVIDENCE.
THAT’S WHY YOU PUT A CAREER
PROSECUTOR THAT IS A POLITICAL
LIKE JOHN DURHAM IN THAT
POSITION.
WERE EVER THE EVIDENCE TAKES.
JOE BIDEN DID MAKE THE UNMASKING
REQUEST AND WASN’T INVOLVED IN
ANY OF THE FLINT DECISIONS, THAN
SO BE, BUT SOMEONE NEEDS TO KNOW
IT.
WHAT I TOOK THAT TO MEAN IS
THERE IS NO EVIDENTIARY SUPPORT
FOR IT YET BUT I DON’T THINK
DURHAM IS THROUGH EITHER.
YOU DON’T KNOW UNTIL YOU TALK TO
THE WITNESSES.
THAT IS ON POINT WITH THE FBI.
YOU DON’T KNOW WHO LEAKED UNTIL
YOU ASK THEM.
>> Martha: SO OBVIOUSLY,
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS GOING TO GET
SOME PUSHBACK FROM THE
PRESIDENT’S SUPPORTERS ON THIS
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOK AT
THESE SITUATIONS FROM THE
BEGINNING AND SAY NO ONE HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
IT’S BEEN AN ENORMOUS SOURCE OF
FRUSTRATION FOR A LOT OF THE
PRESIDENT SUPPORTERS IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND THEY’VE ALSO PUSHED
BACK ON YOU ABOUT THAT WITH NOT
SUBPOENAING SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES ABOUT WHY YOU DIDN’T
SUBPOENA MORE ACTIVELY WHEN YOU
HAD THE CHANCE TO DO SO.
YOU HAVE ANY REGRETS ABOUT THAT?
>> I WAS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS FROM THE MOMENT I
GOT INTO CONGRESS.
I DIDN’T VOLUNTEER FOR THEM, I
WAS DRAFTED FOR MOST OF THEM, SO
YOU WHEN I COULD HAVE AN ENTIRE
HOUR ON THE MISTAKES I’VE MADE.
I WAS NOT THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
DEVIN NUNES WAS AND HE DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB.
BOB GOODLATTE WAS THE CHAIRMAN
AND HE DID A PHENOMENAL JOB.
SO WHOEVER THINKS THAT I FAILED
TO ISSUE SUBPOENAS EITHER
DOESN’T UNDERSTAND THE WAY
CONGRESS WORKS OR JUST WANTS TO
DO A DRIVE-BY SHOOTING, AND I’M
NOT RUNNING AGAIN.
SO I DON’T KNOW WHAT THREAT I
POSED TO THEM.
BUT THERE ARE PLENTY OF THINGS
TO CRITICIZE ME FOR, JUST DON’T
PICK THE WRONG ONE.
>> Martha: ONE OF THE THINGS I
REMEMBER YOU SAYING IS CONGRESS
DOESN’T HAVE THE POWER TO
PROSECUTE.
AND THAT’S ONE OF THE ISSUES IN
TERMS OF THE ROLE OF CONGRESS.
BUT ONE OTHER QUESTION FOR YOU
BECAUSE I HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT
THIS IN THE BACK AND FORTH, YOU
TALKED ABOUT GOING TO THE FBI
AND GETTING ASSURANCES ABOUT
CERTAIN THINGS WITH REGARD TO
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION AND
THEN LEARNING A LOT MORE IN
DOCUMENTS THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO
SEE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THAT CHANGED YOUR MIND ABOUT
WHAT YOU HAD HEARD HER
ORIGINALLY IN THAT BRIEFING, AND
I THOUGHT THAT WAS INTERESTING.
HIM AND IT MAKES ME WONDER WHEN
HE LEFT THE BACK HAD DISCUSSION
WITH CHRISTOPHER WRAY, DO YOU
THINK THAT HE WAS MISLEADING TO
YOU?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION WHAT
DEVON AND I WERE TOLD IN THE
BRIEFINGS DID NOT MATCH UP WITH
THE DOCUMENTS.
SO THE MISTAKE I MADE WHICH I
WILL CONFESS TO IS BELIEVING THE
WORD OF DOJ AND FBI OFFICIALS
THAT CAME AFTER TRUMP WAS
ELECTED.
LET’S BE REALLY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
I WASN’T IN THE ROOM WITH
JIM COMEY AND PETER STRZOK.
I WAS IN THE ROOM WITH PEOPLE
THAT CAME AFTER.
I SHOULD’VE GOTTEN THE DOCUMENTS
FIRST, I’M GLAD I GOT THEM THREE
WEEKS LATER.
>> Martha: I AM NOT ASKING
ABOUT YOUR ACTIONS PARADIGM
ASKING ABOUT CHRISTOPHER WRAY
HERE BECAUSE IF HE WAS NOT
FORTHCOMING IN THE DOCUMENTS
REVEALED SOMETHING SEPARATE, DO
YOU THINK THAT HE IS THE PERSON
THAT SHOULD BE RUNNING THE FBI?
>> I DID NOT PICK HIM, I WILL
TELL YOU THIS, THE FBI TOLD US
THAT NOTHING HAPPEN BEFORE
CERTAIN DATES THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
WAS NOT THE TARGET, YOU LOOK AT
THAT ORIGINATION AND IT MENTIONS
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT’S WHEN MY MIND SWITCHED.
WHEN I LOOKED AT THE DOCUMENTS,
IT DID NOT MATCH UP WITH THE
BRIEFING THAT WE HAD RECEIVED.
>> Martha: ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE